- It's my pleasure today to introduce
Professor Vicente L. Rafael,
who as you know is about as well-respected
and well-known as it is
possible to be in academia.
And we are really delighted
to be able to host him
in our modest Brown Bag
Series here at Yale.
Many of you will know his
justifiably famous works
on the historical and cultural politics
of the colonial and
post-colonial Philippines
including modern classics such
as "Contracting Colonialism,"
"White Love and Other
Events in Filipino History"
"The Promise of the Foreign,"
and "Motherless Tongues."
He's also the editor of
several important collections
in Southeast Asian studies.
And if you go visit the Duke
University press website
and search Vicente L. Rafael
you'll pretty much see
that he is the central core
of their post-colonial studies series,
really in some way it's
brings Duke's reputation
in that field into fruition.
Now, me personally,
I first learned of professor
Raphael's importance
when I was a PhD student at Cornell,
when I had the privilege of taking courses
with Benedict Anderson
and James T. Siegel.
And although Ben and Jim are
rarely impressed by anyone
they would always speak in reverend tones
when they would recount the stories
of their greatest student Vicente Raphael.
Perhaps I would say the
only of their students
who could encounter their charisma
without being shocked into submission.
The rest of us, when we
would meet Jim and Ben
would become sort of silent to use,
the way Jim might phrase it,
we'd become like corpses in
the face of their charisma.
But Vince, it seems has been
able to harness the energy
of their teaching without
becoming devoured by it.
Today's talk offers a sneak
preview of a forthcoming book
on the politics and aesthetics
of the Duterte regime.
It's entitled, "The Sovereign Trickster:
"Death And Laughter in
the Age of Duterte."
And that book will soon be published
by Duke University press.
Please join me today in
welcoming Vicente Raphael
for his talk entitled "Duterte's Phallus:
"On the Aesthetics of
Authoritarian Vulgarity."
And I will share the screen
and once this sheet screen is
shared he will begin his talk.
- It's really a pleasure to be here
even if it's just a
virtual kind of meeting.
I noticed many, many friends
and colleagues that I
haven't seen in a while.
So hello everyone.
Thanks so much for coming.
And again, thank you for
facilitating this Erik and Chris
and the rest of the students and staff
at the Southeast Asia program.
As Erik mentioned this
is a talk that spun out
of one of the chapters
of my forthcoming book.
And if you would like during the Q and A
to sort of expand some
of the arguments I make
in this chapter and connected
with everything else
I've been trying to figure out in the book
I'd be more than happy to.
So let me begin by,
first of all by locating my paper.
Okay, one of the things that
if you've sort of even
briefly been following
events in the Philippines,
since the election of Duterte
two things you notice
one is that he remains enormously popular
despite all the sort
of arguably disastrous
and near genocidal policies
he's adopted in the Philippines.
And the second thing is that
he's also sort of remarkably vulgar
and people have tried to sort
of establish the connection
between his popularity and
his vulgarity, his obscenity.
And in this paper I sort of
try to connect the two as well.
In terms of asking a very basic question
which is what are the sources
of his symbolic authority?
How has he managed to
occupy such a central place
in the imaginative life of Filipinos,
both supporters and critics alike,
as well as those at home and abroad?
And one of the ways in which
the president lays claim to both national
and global attention is
through his stories and jokes.
I mean, he's a consummate storyteller.
And so the humor comes
as part of the stories
that he likes to tell.
He's widely known for his
irreverence and body humor
that constitute important
elements of his governing style.
And it's really that
I def want connect.
I want the connection between
his storytelling abilities
and his governing style.
His stories reveal a reliance on invective
and an obsession with obscenity.
He also makes frequent
references to genitalia,
his as well as those of his critics,
to the delight of his listeners.
He revels in what the
philosopher, a Shield of Bombay
calls an aesthetic of vulgarity
that has the effect of establishing
a relationship of conviviality
between himself and his audience,
which results is a kind
of intimate tyranny,
much of it's centered on
the tales of his phallus
as it encounters the world.
So, for example,
and here we could start
with the next slide.
For example, in his campaign
events in April, 2016
Duterte addressed the Makati Business Club
which is about a sedate
and as conservative setting
as you can imagine,
made up of wealthy
businessmen in the country,
rather than talk about
his economic policies,
though he regaled the
audience with stories
about his use of Viagra.
So he says, for example,
well I'm separated from my
wife, annulled, so I'm useless.
So I'm not useless, I'm not paralyzed.
What am I supposed to do with
my goddam thing down there?
Let it hang forever?
Well, there's no drama going on,
I drank Viagra and then it stood up.
Oh let's not kid ourselves,
I am giving it to you raw.
I thought you were all the same age here.
So he starts with a story, right?
And here you can see what
Duterte shares with men
of a certain age and
considerable influence,
his story about his experience
of emasculation followed by rejuvenation.
Thanks to appeal, he regains his heart on
the material evidence of a phallic power
that he thought he had lost.
Laughter ensues as he
discursively shows to the men
a part of himself that
should have been hidden.
His obscenity consists of
making the private public
reaching below to
connect with those above.
It is this sexual politics
from below that binds Duterte
to these men, along with
a sprinkling of women
who joined in the laughter.
Together they share a common fantasy
about the authoritarian phallus
as something they can
imaginatively access,
and the prospective pleasures
of a drug induced erection
beginning with that of Duterte's.
But as we shall see,
in other examples below
the presidential phallus comes across
not only as an instrument of pleasure,
but also as a sign of terror.
In another campaign stop
at a large sports complex
in Caisson City around the
same time around early 2016
Duterte tells a story that
reverberated around the world,
and some of you may have
remembered this particular tale.
He says that while he was
a mayor in Davao in 1989
there occurred a bloody
prison siege in Davao City.
Among the dead was one of the hostages
taken by the prisoners,
a 36 year old Australia
missionary, Jacqueline Hamill.
According to Duterte,
she was repeatedly raped by the prisoners
along with other women
hostages before being killed.
But rather than evoke Patheos,
the sight of Hamill’s corpse
stares desire in the mayor.
And if it can have the next slide, please.
All the women were raped
during that first assault
because they retreated the
bodies they used as shields.
One of them was a corpse
of the Australian woman lay minister.
Tsk, this was a problem.
When the bodies were brought
out, they were wrapped.
I looked at her face, son of a bitch,
she looked like a
beautiful American actress.
Son of a bitch , what a waste!
And son of a bitch here is
it was a very common Filipino curse.
What came to mind was they
raped her, they took turns.
I was angry because she was
raped, that's one thing,
but she was so beautiful,
the mayor should have
gone first son of a bitch,
what a waste, Sayang.
Okay, so much for that slide.
Here Hamill's rape and
death is used by Duterte
as a setup for a joke about
himself, more specifically
about the arousal and
frustration of his lost.
He sees her dead body
and her beautiful face
and he feels like he should
have been the first in line
to assault her.
Instead, he comes too late
and isn't able to come at all.
It is his failure to assert
his claim on the woman's body
that is presumably taken by his audience
as the object of hilarity.
Seeing her dead body fills him
neither would rage nor grief
but with a desire that
cannot be fulfilled.
He is unable to discharge
his authority as it were.
The horror of the scene is just displaced
into a story about a mayor
lamenting the failure of his phallic power
rather than the erectile victory
celebrated in the first story,
the second ends with a
punchline Sayang, what a pity
receded by the cuss word
Hutangnya, son of a bitch.
But all is not lost.
Duterte's disclosure of desire unfulfilled
and phallic authority
undercut produces a payback.
The audience laughs and their
laughter compensates him
for his lost power.
It returns to him, both the
pleasure and the authority
that the dead prisoners
and the woman's corpse
had deprived him, unable to pull rank.
The mayor is nevertheless rewarded
with the people's recognition
of his narrative performance.
Reports to the story drew sharp rebukes
from feminists human rights advocates
and the Australian and U.S Embassy
as well as many other quarters.
But among most of the electorate
his popularity soared.
Horrifying his critics but
delighting his supporters
with his pungent shamelessness,
Duterte's bad language and
obscene stories were crucial
to propelling him to the presidency.
And tracking his jokes,
we can see a set of obsessions
built around the question,
who gets to own the phallus,
who gets to wield it and for what purpose?
Here the phallus should be understood
less as a biological things
synonymous with a penis
as a symbolic weapon for
asserting autocratic authority
and patriarchal prerogatives
over women and men alike.
Like guns, cars are wealth,
the phallus can be used
to impress and to threaten
to unify and to disperse,
to induce pleasure but
also to coerce submission.
Duterte routinely threatens
to castrate his opponents,
even as he repeatedly reveals
his generous endowment.
He used to event imagine hearts
and shore up fragile ego,
Duterte phallus proved effective
in shutting down his opposition.
The presidential phallus, however,
is far from being an unassailable force.
As we saw in the rape story above,
it can also be blunted by other men
and women whose death frustrated
Duterte's assertion of his privileges.
Indeed, Duterte is notorious
for joking about rape
as a way of reasserting his ability
to police women's behavior
and enlist men into affirming
the sexism that buttresses
his authoritarian imagination.
Hence, when critics point out
that contrary to his claims
crime and Davao while he was
a mayor had actually gone up
especially rape.
He retorts that wherever
there are beautiful women
there will be plenty of rape.
Along the same lines he
also spoke approvingly
of men who had the
balls to rape candidates
for miss universe in exchange
for facing certain punishment.
Women are raped, not simply
because they are women
for Duterte, it is because
they are "beautiful."
It is as if their beauty is a challenge
that has to be faced down,
a provocation its proper place
under the rule in the
service of the phallus.
The philosopher, Kate Mann
has a very interesting and
useful description of misogyny.
And perhaps let me just cite it here
as a way of framing the Duterte's
own particular misogyny.
He says, "Misogyny is what
happens when women break ranks
"or rules and disrupt
the patriarchal order.
"They tend to be perceived
as uppity unruly,
"out of line or insubordinate.
"Misogyny isn't simply hateful,
"it produces social costs
on noncompliant women.
"Think of misogyny then as
the law enforcement branch
"of a patriarchal order.
"That makes for a useful if rough contrast
"between misogyny and sexism.
"Whereas misogyny upholds the
social norms of patriarchy
"by patrolling and policing them,
"sexism serves to justify those norms
"largely via an ideology of
supposedly natural differences
"between men and women with
respect to their talents,
"interests, proclivities and appetite.
"Sexism is bookish, misogyny is combative.
"Sexism is complacent,
misogyny is anxious.
"Sexism has a theory,
misogyny wields a cudgel."
In joking about rape, Duterte,
and here we can go back to me.
In joking about rape Duterte
upholds patriarchal norms
and sexist attitudes by wheeling
the "cudgel of misogyny."
And that cudgel is the phallus
at once combative and anxious,
always wary of challenges
and eager to assert itself.
One particularly disturbing story
that illustrates the law
enforcement role of misogyny
involves Duterte encouraging soldiers
when confronted with
communist female fighters
to spare their lives but
to shoot them into vagina.
"There's a new order
coming from the mayor,
"we won't kill you, we will
just shoot your vagina,
"so that if she has no vagina
"then she would be useless."
Shooting them in their vagina was in a way
taking away what made them women.
It was their punishment for taking up arms
and defying the state.
It amounted to castrating those
who challenged the patriarchal norms
integral to the exercise
of the state's authority.
Hence we see how Duterte's misogyny
is directed not at every
women, but at particular women
who attempt to seize the
phallus for themselves,
daring to go against this
political and sexual authority
and conversely women who
affirm his phallic power
are richly rewarded for that reason.
Now Duterte's phallic
power is directed, however,
not just at women but as we
saw above at other men as well
to make sure that they to fall in line.
For example, while campaigning
for senatorial candidates
during the midterm elections of 2018,
Duterte installed the size of his penis
in order to set them apart from
the called ugly candidates,
running in the opposition.
Well one's character is important,
penis size, he claimed, was crucial.
Had God given him a small
penis, he continued,
he would have gone to the
church alter and cut it off
saying son of a bitch is
this all you have given me?
Encouraged by the crowd's laughter
he then recalled how he
would walk around naked
in the hallways of the
wide WCA as a young man
while everyone else
covered up with a towel.
He went about proudly displaying his junk.
The other residents would
look on an admiration,
and here you could show
the next slide please.
"They tell me son of a bitch
Duterte, you are so hard.
"When I was young, my penis
almost looked up to the sky,
"moving the microphone
upwards to make the point.
"Its head would almost
reach his belly button.
"I'm very thankful to my father.
"At least he led me out into
the world highly equipped."
He finishes by recalling how
women at a local bordello
were shocked at the sight of his member.
They ran away, they said referring to me,
"We don't like him, that skinny guy
"he won't stop having sex."
Some much for that slide.
In his youth, Duterte claims,
he literally stood out
creating a vivid impression
among both men and women.
While men envied his penis
women, however, ran away in fright.
Wishing to have a phallus like his,
the other men acknowledged
Duterte possession
of its power, precisely
for the respect it arouses
in other men and the
fear of sexual violence
it steers among women.
Merging masculinity with misogyny,
Duterte's phallocentric politics
is central to his
authoritarian imagination
using the image of his penis
to put both men and women
in their putative places.
This brings to mind Helene Cixous,
"Within the phallocratic apparatus,
"women are subordinated
and defined by lack
"while men are given the
grotesque an unenviable fate
"of being reduced to a single idle
"with balls of clay."
We could further see Duterte's
phallocentric politics
at work in the following example.
In a speech in 2019 Duterte
had reacted to the rumors
that he had a kidney cancer
and he was dying from colon cancer.
The target of his ire was Kit
Tatad, former cabinet minister
during the Marcos'
regime and a major figure
and a major figure in the
ultra conservative Catholic
say Opus dei.
In his newspaper columns,
he had written about Duterte illness
and frequent absences from public view,
suggesting that he was
on the verge of dying.
Duterte responded by saying
and here we can go to the next slide.
"This Tatad he said, my day is coming.
"That I was confined, serious
in and out of the hospital
"with colon cancer.
"Nearly every day he was going on and on.
"You read the newspaper,
"I mean, how unfair can you get every day?
"Even I started to believe it.
"So one day I undressed to take a shower.
"I held my, without my
underwear, I held my anus.
"I smelled it, smelled like shit,
"and not some other dot dot."
Next slide please.
Yeah, "He said I was
already dead, so I hit back.
"I said this Tatad, you
Tatad son of a bitch,
"I would admit it if I was sick.
"You son of a you have a serious case
"for 30 years of diabetes.
"Your dick and no longer, "
and then he raises the
microphone to the laughter
and applause of the audience.
"When you have diabetes 30
years," drops the microphone
"no more I said, let me borrow
your wife for one night.
"I let her hold my body go on.
"Your insult hurt a lot,
"you son of a bitch you're asking for it.
"You said I was rude, well,
son of a bitch that's true.
"You said I was no statesmen,
well, that's true."
Okay so, so much for that slide.
Now let's break this down for a second.
The president has always
been particularly sensitive
about rumors regarding his health,
despite the fact that
it's various illnesses
that have been widely reported
and takes particular umbrage
at those this suggests
that he is close to that store.
Duterte takes his revenge in
the form of returning Tatad's
putative insults with interest,
but he takes his time getting there.
He recaps the rumor,
acknowledging its power to compel belief
through its repeated circulation.
And it's this recapping,
that's part of a
storytelling sort of style.
To make sure that he
doesn't have colon cancer,
he talks about poking around his anus
and smelling his fingers,
reassuring himself that it smelled of shit
rather than some other cancerous odor.
Discursively exposing his
anus, he also exposes himself
not only to the possibility of being sick,
but also to the
possibility of being duped.
Assured that his anal stink
is nothing out of the ordinary
he goes on the attack.
Punctuating his remarks
with crisp invectives,
he points out that it is in fact Tatad
who has been ill with
diabetes for many years
and as a result can no longer
get his autin or dick up.
The consummate performer
that he is Duterte,
to makes a point of illuminating this
with the use of the microphone as a prop.
He raise it up and down
to show what he can do with his penis
and what Tatad can no longer do with his.
He goes from exploring his
anus to scrutinizing his penis
linking the two as signs
of his good health.
And the clench hi case, he
asks the borrow Tatad's wife
so he can verify the
hardness of his erection
as compared to the flat sadness of Tatad.
His mouth and anus
come to the aid of the
presidential phallus.
Together, they marshal
a barrage of obscenity
that meets with the laughter
and applause of the audience.
In this way, Duterte effectively
unmanneds his opponent
Tatad stories depicted Duterte
in a state of bodily crisis.
Feeling aggrieved, the president hits back
showing that in fact
he remains in command.
Beginning with his
control of the narrative
in his ability to reverse
reverse its target.
Returning the insult with interest
Duterte that draws a third
person into the scene,
Tatad's wife, who is pictured as complicit
in the Duterte's revenge in
effect, holding her husband
with the intention for
her to grasp his thing.
I have one last story
and perhaps it is the
most previewing interest
of Duterte's power of story telling.
It is a little bit extended
so I hope it will feel indulging.
And so it's kind of ironic
when I do this paper.
So because they talk about
the Duterte's storytelling
by telling my own stories.
Anyway, this story of
being it is this story
that he's totally obsessed
when it comes back
to over and over again,
which is the story of
being sexually abused
at around the age of 14 by
an American Jesuit priest
during confession.
He often returns to the story
as a way of casting aspersions
at the Catholic church
that has been critical
of his human rights abuse.
So there's a very strategic reason
for him to go back to the
story again and again.
Folded into his story, however,
is another his sexual abuse
of their household help
which he later confesses
was in fact, a fabrication.
Here, what we see is a double
confession in this story,
Duterte to the priest and to the audience
and a double assault,
the priests on Duterte
and Duterte on the maid.
The two acts of violation turn
out to be intimately related
whereby the priests assault on Duterte
becomes a means for the latter's
domination of his audience.
He frequently told these
stories on various occasions
in his usual mix of
Tigerish, Bisaya an English.
Below, what I provide with
followers is a translation
of a composite version
of his this one long continuous story.
So let's start with a slide,.
Now in Ateneo who here is from Ateneo.
If you are from Ateneo on Friday,
it's communion, confession,
that's automatic.
And during confession bless
me father for I have sin.
And what is your sin?
Well, it is standing up because
you are funding my prick.
While confessing the
priest fondle our balls.
So when you confess, they ask
you what are your sins my son?
I was a freshmen, what
was the sin of a freshmen?
Next slide please.
I, l,
come on, I, I, I, I is not a sin.
We do not have the whole day, speak up.
I went to the, what I went
to the room of the maid, why?
I lifted the blanket, and?
I tried to touch what was
inside the panty, and?
I was touching, she woke
up, so I left the room.
Where did you go after that?
To the bathroom, why Kuwan father,
yung the usual, well, father
the usual, next slide please.
What the usual?
Alam mo you know, okay,
so you went back and?
I tried to insert my finger father.
Then?
I, there was hair and, and?
It was wet and did she wake up?
No, father, she was closing
her eyes fast asleep
or sabi ng pari, the priest said, and?
I went to the bathroom again father,
Again?
Yes, father twice.
Oh, by God, say five our father's,
five hail Mary's because
you will go to hell.
Next slide, please.
That is the explanation
behind the finger story.
The priests would urge
you to tell more sins.
What sins could first,
second and third year students commit?
Wolf whistling women was the
only thing that we committed?
But father Falvey he was always urging you
to tell him more sins.
Come on, come on, give me
your sins, do you know why?
Because the longer you stay there
the more he can fondle your balls.
And there were many priests,
they would just divide
the students among them.
If you believe the story
that I fingered a woman you are crazy.
I only said it because
the priest was insistent
that we tell him more and more sins,
so we could stay kneeling
while he squeezed our balls.
Son of a bitch that's the truth.
So much for that slide so
we can go back to it to me.
So what do we make of this really,
I mean, it's a really interesting story?
Now, many of Duterte's stories
are arguably confessional
to the extent that they are about exposing
what usually stays hidden
bringing to light what
otherwise remains in darkness.
The subject who speaks
is also the subject who is spoken about,
as she reveals the story of
their sinful acts to a priest
who in turn dispenses
penance in the name of God.
As the mediator of divine forgiveness,
the priest exercises an
inordinate amount of power
over the penitent
registering penitence debts,
and prescribing penitence
with which to cancel
these subject, of course.
So they talked about in my earlier work.
However, in Duterte's telling
the very active confession is subverted,
it is no longer meant to seek forgiveness
and acknowledge the priests' authority
but precisely to ridicule it.
Duterte reveals the priests concupiscence
showing how confession becomes a vehicle,
not for forgiveness
but for clerical abuse.
Confession breeds obscenity
rather than divine dispensation
making for an uncanny
encounter between the priest
and the penitent.
What emerges in the
experience of confession
for the penitence and here a young boy
is the return of the
repressed in a familiar form.
The predator as father or
the father is predator.
From the perspective of the boy
the father's demands appear autocratic.
He cannot be refused,
this lust for the boy
requires that the latter
must stay longer in the confessional
making up sins in order
to satisfy the priest.
To comply with the priest's demands,
Duterte claims he made up a story
about fingering their housemate
then masturbating twice in the bathroom.
He evokes a circle of touching
while the priest fondles his genitals
Duterte talks about fondling himself
on the genitals of the
woman as she sleeps,
then subsequently fondling himself.
His story connects these
improper connections
into a sequence of submission and mastery
that yields pleasure and laughter.
The trauma of sexual abuse for Duterte
at the hands of the priest is transmuted
into the excitement of
probing the maid's genitals
then mastering as it for his own.
This mixture of fear, shame and excitement
is registered in the
Duterte stuttering reply
to the priest insistence that
he tell him more and more.
I, I, he says as the
priest holding his balls
fishes for more demanding and, then, and.
Duterte's confession climaxes as it were
with the two trips to the
bathroom to relieve himself.
In the end, the priest waves them off
with a few feckless prayers,
assuring him of eternal damnation.
Rather than the site for
the for the contrition
and divine forgiveness,
confession here is converted
into a kind of pornographic machine
for the reproduction of
sadistic male pleasures.
Duterte submits to the clerical abuse
but turns that submission
into a story about his mastery
over the maid who remains
apparently innocent
of his violation.
His exposure, and this
empowerment by someone above
become the conditions for
overtime empowering someone below.
He does reverse this disposition
from being abused to being the abuser,
from a position of submission
to one of domination,
from one of fear to one of
satisfaction and release.
But only at the expense and
through the exploitation
of a subordinate other.
Well, what are the audience?
Feminists Human rights
advocates, church hierarchy
and other critics of Duterte
typically reacted with anger.
They decried as misogyny at
making light of a sexual abuse
as consistent with this
disregard for human rights.
Others were scandalized by his
decency and filthy language
is lack of el ca dessa
or civilized behavior.
In other words, they
read Duterte's obscenity
in the way that he had meant it
as unwinning war on social conventions.
Judging from the
transcripts and the videos,
however, those who were
present at his speeches
reacted differently.
They doubled up in laughter,
they applauded his stories,
laughed at his jokes, why would this be?
Now Freud once post this question
when we laugh at jokes, what
are we really laughing at?
Are we responding to the
technique of joke telling
or to the content of the joke or to both?
It is never clear, he says.
To the extent that jokes
like dreams are fulfillments
of the same wish to evade repression,
"The joke will evade restrictions
"and open sources of pleasure
that have become inaccessible.
"It will further bribe the
hero with its yield of pleasure
"and to taking sides with us
"without very close investigation.
"Reason, critical judgment suppression.
"These are the forces against
"which a joke fights in succession.
"Now the political significance of jokes,
" the fact that they go against the grain
"of the reasonable and the normal
"would seem to make the valuable
resources for the oppressed
"seeking to overthrow
the weight of authority."
Mikhail Biotene, further argues
that medieval celebrations
like the carnival and modern
literary forums like the novel
are sites for this upending of hierarchy
through satire, disguise,
and social inversions.
The high is brought down
low and the low is elevated
especially parts of the
body and its functions
Writing his audience,
Duterte is like a
smuggler of illicit goods,
promising forbidden pleasure
and overturning repressive strictures.
He says, he says what the
audience would have wanted
to say but to could not.
Their laughter could this be read
as signs of their identification
with Duterte's efforts to
find a way out of a suffering
at the hands of the priest,
with a tale about abusing the maid
who nonetheless remains
unaware of her violation.
They delight in his resistance
and at his bumbling attempts at mastery
that leads to some sort of self recovery.
Decades later when he tells
his story he's no longer a boy,
but the president of the country.
Occupying the Heights of power
he is capable of commanding attention
wherever he goes and whatever he says.
Duterte's obscenities feels the aversive.
But his aversion in this context
is in the service of an autocratic end
where laughter produces an
intimacy between ruler and rude.
The vulgarity of his
language positions him
as a kind of rebel,
inviting others to join him
in his assault on bushwa
sensibilities and norms.
But it comes with the condition
that the audience must
submit to his narrative.
Only can tell the stories
and expect their laughter.
The reverse is never possible
as no one as far as I know
jokes with Duterte in public.
He expects no narrative reciprocity,
no return with interest,
but only a kind of passive acceptance
of the surplus of stories he gives you.
There is nothing democratic
in Duterte's humor.
Instead, the pleasure that the
audience gets from the jokes
is intrinsically linked to
their willingness to participate
in the imaginative violation
of others, especially women.
Whether he seeks revenge or release
Duterte's tales seek to
assert his phallic power
over his enemies while
simultaneously subordinating
and overpowering his audience.
And looking at the narrative
structures of this jokes
we see how it hinges
not only on the classic
techniques of joke telling
those of condensation and
displacement as in dreams,
it's also productive of
a hierarchy of listening
whereby Duterte as the
teller monopolizes the time
and the language of telling.
As part of the audience,
you have no choice,
but to wait for him.
And he is always late, always late.
And then listen to him take
his time, unschooling his tales
unable to leave without drawing his ire,
you remain a captive audience.
Jokes then become a way of
establishing his authority.
He exposes himself,
renders himself vulnerable
and risks dissolving his authority,
but only to recover and
reassert his mastery
over the scene of exposure.
This dialectic of
disclosure and domination
allows him to forge a tyranny of intimacy,
extracting your consent
registered by your laughter.
You were, is this a means
of playing out his anxiety
while acid aging has fear,
vulgarity is stylized
and obscenity perform
to release the audience
audiences inhibition
at the fine conventions.
But (voiceover) bogus
and deeply conservative
since it always comes with
the price of submission
to the Duterte's
authoritarian imagination.
While laughter creates
conviviality and community
it is always shadowed
by violence and fear.
Duterte recreates and every story
something of the tone and
texture of his primal scene,
the dark confessional
where he is held captive
at the hands of an American priest,
indeed is performative
shamelessness today,
maybe read as the unfinished struggle
to master his fear of the father predator
as he attempts to take on the
ladders power for himself.
It is precisely that same phallic power
that he seeks to grasp and wield
when he addresses those who
considers critical of him,
such as women and lesser men.
And especially abject
figures of criminality
like drug dealers and users.
Recklessly cussing at them,
he lost after their deaths,
brooking neither descent or opposition,
and, and then, and thanks a lot.
That's it.
- Thank you.
It's dropped by all of
us for a fantastic talk.
We'll take a moment just to
use our handclap functions
and this is really quite wonderful.
So we will now open up to a
question and answer period.
I will moderate the Q and A here.
So if anyone has any questions,
I'd like to ask you to
use the hand raise function if possible.
And if that's not possible
to turn on your video
and wildly wave your hands
so that I can try to see you.
But that doesn't always work
because I can't see every basis.
So let's get started,
does anyone want to start us
off with the first question?
- Yeah, so, you know,
what I find most curious
is this tremendous popularity
Duterte continues to have
do we know, is that gendered,
do women support him as much as men?
- You know, as far as I can tell,
yes, the popularity holds
as much across genders
as far as I can tell.
I mean, of course there's,
there's all kinds of nuance
and you know, these surveys
are really difficult
to figure out, but both
anecdotal and survey results
seem to suggest that
Duterte remains popular.
And there was a survey late last year
which put his popularity as far
up as 91% ridiculous amount.
And you know, and it
hasn't really gone down
despite his mishandling
of the COVID crisis
and sort of failed rollout
of vaccines and so forth.
He just, I mean, and part of it
is because the opposition is also so weak.
The opposition hasn't been
able to offer an alternative
narrative, much less,
better jokes than Duterte.
So for that reason I think he remains
astoundingly popular so.
- Just a quick follow-up,
I mean, it seems that some
of there's a kind of release of as,
from a sense of humiliation quite often,
when you have this kind
of reactionary humor.
And it just, I mean, from my time,
you know, in living among
Bi. sains in Mendota,
there was a systematic
humiliation by the educated
and by the church and by,
you know, the kind of targets
that Trump also has similar targets here,
and that kind of class
humiliation would seem
to override the gender, right.
As many women feel humiliated
by the elite as men do.
And if the, yeah,
it's like owning the
liberals in this country
if he upsets the educated
classes, then that's enough.
- Yeah and the other complicating
factor here is the church.
So the source also comes from
from the church hierarchy.
So, yeah.
- Thanks for that great
question and answer.
We have a question from Paul Sarno,
then after that it will be John Sydell ask
Ahmasa Ronbu, Amy Chang, and Eubert.
- I thought there was a time
when he called President
Obama the son of a whore?
Did it translation problem there,
or what exactly did he say?
- Well, you know, the
term he uses is pukangna
which is the most common.
Literally Puta-Koh, right?
So people tend to translate as that,
but I mean in the case
of Obama and others,
where he uses that term
and you can easily
translate as motherfucker.
You know which is the other
common way of referring to him.
And of course it's always
laced with a racist connotation
especially when he
criticizes black leaders
there's always a racist
undertone to it as well, yeah.
- And he call ambassador Goldberg
that Jewish ambassador?
- Yeah, not only Jewish
ambassador, but a bakla
which is to say a gay,
a bakla which is to say
gay, gay ambassador.
- Gay, what's that about?
- Well, I mean, as far as
I know Goldberg was gay,
he was out but Filipinos
have used that against him.
And with Duterte his relationship
to homosexuality is it's
a little bit complicated.
He's both homophiliac when necessary
and homophobic then called for.
So he could do either of both.
So he will flirt with, for
example, a gay audience
and even claimed that at
one point in his life,
he was probably gay.
And then, and would say things like,
well, I'm really for gay marriage
because I think people
should be able to marry
whoever they want.
But then at another point use gay slurs
to attack his enemies, right?
Call attention to the size of their butt,
and what, you know what they do
with it and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So he's very deceptive in that sense.
- Thanks, we have a
question from John Sidel.
- Yeah, thank you, Erik
and really nice to see you Vincente
and to get a taste of the
forthcoming book real pleasure.
Two questions.
One is sort of,
if you could sort of follow
up on what you were saying
in response to Tom
Gibson about the church.
If we think of Bucktin's argument
about that rubber, lazy and laughter
that the irreverence is kind of productive
of something politically,
the challenges, authority.
Clearly the churches is somehow
very strongly in the mix
and it's worth perhaps
noting that Kit Tatad
is famously a member of Opus Dei.
And I wonder that they're
also the comments,
you know that Duterte made about the Pope.
And even Obama one could think of Obama
as a rather pious, you
know, kind of persona
and Duterte's predecessor Aquino,
although, you know promoting
a reproductive health act
that the church opposed
was also a kind of churchy
momma's boy Ateneo,
educated and all the rest of it.
So that's one question.
The second question is
you use that sort of classic phrase,
I think, which I've
seen in other contexts,
like in Sweden when people
talk about populism,
there's a book in Swedish
that something like we
say what you're feeling,
and sense of speaking what
people are really thinking,
but are not allowed in polite society
to express and the vicarious pleasure
of that transgressive
speech act and behavior.
And that seems to be
something which scholars
of populism see in many contexts.
So I guess I'm curious
whether you might be tempted
to extrapolate from Duterte
for other populace like him.
I think there was someone in recent memory
in American history but
I can't really remember
where that might've been, I
think I blanked it somehow.
- Yeah, yeah we all wish we could.
First of all the question of the church.
You know the church remains
is one of the staunchest
of holders of a certain
kind of moral authority
in the Philippines has long history
of sort of critic critiquing
political figures.
All the way back from the
Spanish colonial period
to, you know most
recently the Marcos regime
and then again, Duterte.
So the church has sort
of positioned itself
as the moral voice that
will criticized Duterte
especially his war on drugs,
his pronouncements on women,
his violation of human rights,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And since the country is largely Catholic,
they do continue to enjoy a
certain amount of influence.
And Duterte has done something very smart
which is he sort of done an end run
around the church and called
them on their corruption.
Which it's kind of like a public secret
where everybody knows
the church is corrupt
but then no one will talk about it.
And so what he's done is he is capitalized
on this public secret.
You know, he's criticized
bishops for having cars,
for having mistresses this and that.
And then of course there is this deep down
sort of primal story in his
background of being abused,
that I'm almost certain many people share
and comes at a time
when of course there's this
huge explosion of revelations.
You know, that, I guess this
would be the me too version
of the church abuse, right.
Kids being abused and so forth.
So it comes at a particular conjuncture
particularly historical conjuncture
where the church is right
for being critiqued, right?
So that's one thing.
And Duterte is just the man to do it
because of course, what's the
church going to do, right?
They can condemn it to hell
and he says things like,
oh, I'd rather go to hell
because the women that are more beautiful,
you've got to heaven, you
know, the women are ugly.
Well, what am I gonna do in heave, right?
So, you know, he has a
comeback for everything
in that sense that people think about,
but would never ever for
one minute, say in public.
The second thing about
your question about humor
and, you know, I mean think about the guy
who didn't want a cruise name
you did not want to mention.
I mean, Trump became very popular
mostly because of his
involvement with mass media
and for me, one of the most
memorable things about Trump
is he was very much
involved in in wrestling.
And I'm sure you've all seen
the video of Trump wrestling
doing these four moves
with with Vince McMahon.
And it's that kind of wrestling aesthetic
which is braggadocio
humor, defying convention.
I kind of exorbitant display
of phallic masculinity,
which allows, you know,
certain kinds of people,
certain kinds of men, and
also women, I think to revel
in things that are otherwise
censored or forbidden.
I think that these are crucial elements
of a certain kind of reactionary politics
and the pleasure of fascism, if you will,
the pleasures of fascism
are not to be downplayed
because that's something that permeates,
I think it's something
that permeates the culture
and then coagulates and crystallizes
around certain pronouncements
of certain figures,
and then they become
these celebrities, right?
So I think it's interesting
to think about that.
It's certainly and in this book,
I do have a chapter where I
compared Duterte with Trump
precisely around the question of humor
this kind of repressive humor so.
- Thank you, next question from Ahsmas.
Before we asked the
question I just want to note
that we have professor
Raphael is agreed to stay
till about 1:20 today
so I think we can make it
through all the questions
listed in the chat there
but just do be mindful
of the time as we go through that.
Go ahead and Ahsmas.
- Oh, thanks.
I'll try to be concise
'cause I was really
taken with your analysis
and it was many interesting parallels
in contrast, to make to
figure like Najib in Malaysia.
But I was also really wondering about
what kinds of female figures
feature in Duterte's stories
and what kinds of
patterns are tied to that?
Because it strikes me that there
was a quite different tenor
to the way he speaks about
his violation of the maid
and the sort of almost
celebration of the violation
of the Australian woman.
The other story.
- Yeah.
- And so I wonder, 'cause at least
where I've done field work in, in Malaysia
like all sorts of stories about rape
and sexual relation would
always be related in some way
or sort of touch upon
themes of spiritual danger,
which is and especially the
always fascinating figure
of the Pontianak.
So I was wondering what
kinds of figures are present
and what kinds of, or
even if ideas of witches
and which is sexual danger also involved?
- Yeah, it's a good question.
As far as I can tell,
he doesn't delve into these
sort of supernatural figures
for women
Duterte stories are sort of pretty secular
in their telling as it were.
And so, I mean the Malaysian stuff
sounds a lot more
interesting in many ways,
but Duterte doesn't doesn't
dip into this, why he doesn't?
I'm not sure why, but I'm
sure if you dig deep enough
there'll probably be
some kind of resemblances
to these different ways
of sort of figuring
femininity out of place.
'Cause that's always,
what's at stake, right?
It's always the female
figure out of place,
and how you deal with that?
That's always an invitation.
They're too beautiful, they're too ugly,
they're too wild, they're
too rebellious, whatever.
So this, this idea of
the female out of place
is always an invitation for Duterte
to sort of step in and say,
well I'm gonna put her back in place,
you know which arguably is
the substance of misogyny
that that Kate Mann suggests
in her book, so, yeah.
- Next question from Amy Chang.
- Hello, thank you so much.
I had a related question
about your final anecdote
which like pretty much
everyone else, I'm sure
I heard the first time in the news
and had like a really
strongly negative reaction to
but I was surprised
listening to your analysis.
It really opened up a lot
of the vulnerabilities
that are present in that story,
and I wanted to ask about a
few more things in particular.
For instance,
how precedented is it to be
open about clerical abuse
or like child abuse for like male figures,
politicians or just any other celebrities?
And then the second thing
was I was curious about
like the positioning of
fabrication and innocence
in that story, because he says
like if you think I really did
it then, like, you're crazy
of course I didn't.
And he explains that he
was telling the stories
sort of as a survival strategy,
like when he was being abused as a child
to please this priest
but also to sort of like,
it seems like as you were pointing out
with the circle of touching
like he's trying to tell the priest
that like what the priest is doing to him
is a sin by positioning
himself as a sinner
and saying that he's touching someone else
and therefore, like if you call
this like this masturbation
of an unwitting victim, a
sin, and you should recognize
that what you're doing to me is a sin.
And like each time he goes to the bathroom
I assume to come, it seems
like he's trying to like
bring the tale and thus
the experience to a close
so that the abuse will be over.
But like in each case like
lasts longer than he wants it to
so he has to like continue
telling the story again
so that he can get them to the payoff.
And in that I sort of hear
an accusation of the audience
as well as like, you're crazy
if you think I've done any
of these things at all.
As Ahsmas pointed out, like
the two violation stories
we heard today are both
imaginary violations,
proposed violations that
have been fabricated.
So just, yeah, I was hoping to hear
more about your thoughts there
and maybe how like
what the position of the innocent woman
who is unaware of the
violation that's happening is
or like in the previous case
of the Australian Missionary
like the woman who has died
and so never could
experience his violation
which is like clearly
constructed to be imaginary.
- Yeah, that's a great point.
And now you make me think
about the connection
between the dead woman
and the woman asleep,
both of whom remain
innocent of their violation.
And I think this is again, typical,
of so much of Duterte’s stories
whereby his violation is
compensated by a story
rather, the violation
that's visited upon him
in this case by the priest
is compensated by the story of
his performance or his desire
to perform a similar violation
but two figures who then remain passive
and therefore innocent.
So in other words, it's as if he's saying
he wants to exercise power
but at the same time,
he claims to be innocent
of the consequences of that exercise.
So that's one way to read it.
The second way to read it is,
and again, I don't get as deeply into this
as I probably should
which is that you assume
he's been traumatized.
And the question of trauma of course
is the trauma never resolved, right?
Trauma thrives in repetition
because of its failure to fully represent
what's actually happened.
So in the case of Duterte,
he likes to tell the story
of being traumatized by the priest
precisely because he can't
quite get over it, right?
It's something that goes on and on again,
in that sense it probably resonates
with the traumatic experiences
of his audiences too.
That's what they share,
what they have in common
is their inability to transcend our trauma
and therefore to be
condemned, to repeat it.
But the payoff is the
fact that it's repeated
but at the expense of
certain figures of power,
in this case the priest or whoever it is,
that's traumatized them.
And there's a sort of
interesting connection
with his obsession with drug killings.
I mean, you know, when, when
you hear him talk about addicts
and killing, I mean, he
basically it's the same thing.
I want to kill as many of you
motherfuckers as possible, right?
I'm not gonna be happy until
everyone's dead, right?
I want to kill, kill,
kill, kill, kill, right?
So it's this, again, this repetitiveness
this inability to be able
to sort of find closure
and to return again and again
to the situation of wanting
to violate without end.
At the same time to maintain
that he is saving the country
by killing addicts.
And in that sense, sort of
maintain a certain innocence
even a certain nobility
in what he's doing.
So it's again, just dialectic
of disclosure and domination
that he's thrown back into
as he tries to repeat the same
thing, the same discourse,
the same stories again and again.
And this is what substitutes,
in case of Duterte,
this is what substitutes for policy.
He doesn't have any policies,
his only policy is to act
out as it were his trauma.
If you want to, I mean that's
a little bit simplistic,
but I mean, I think if you wanted to do
like a psychopathological
analysis of what moves this guy,
I mean, I think that's part of it.
- Thank you.
And then if we could also ask
like a brief follow-up question.
I was wondering if you'd
noticed any patterns
in his language use for
parts of his story setups,
because you mentioned he
speaks in Tagalog as in English
and are there, like does he
reserve a certain language
for like certain punchlines
or like for certain setups
or like building towards the climax?
- Yeah, he likes to
speak in, Bisaya, Bisdak.
Bisdak is his first language
and some of his most vulgar
and more colorful anecdotes
are always in Bisdak.
But Tagalog is his second,
actually English second
language Tagalog is his third.
and Tigrish is probably his fourth, right?
And so when he speaks,
he sends two to navigate
through those different
kinds of languages.
And it's the, like
the vaginas shooting the
communist rebels in the vagina,
which is so horrific you
can't even contemplate it,
but he likes to tell that in this Bisdak.
So, yeah.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
The next question is from
Eubert Lennard Torreliza.
- Hello, good afternoon and good morning
here in the Philippines.
So my question is my argument is this
because I have read about Duterte
because I'm trying to write a book
about his phasism because I'm
a creative writing student
from the Philippines from European demands
or if you're aware of, or if, you know
because I have read about from Ateneo,
If I read it correctly.
So Duterte has been diagnosed
or was diagnosed with
narcissistic personality disorder.
So what do you think,
Duterte loves the boast
about this penis?
So is there any studies or theories
why he does this all the time?
And one thing he's also diagnosed
with a pervasive tendency
but the mean humiliate others
and violate other human rights.
So what do you think about sir?
- Yeah, well, I mean, in some
ways this paper is about that
is about reckoning with
these other diagnosis
without completely accepting them.
I mean, I don't need the paper.
In fact, I don't mean the book
to be reductive in that sense
of, you know, everything
can be traced back
to this pathological or
narcissistic condition.
But I do think that that it's impossible
to talk about Duterte's
or it's impossible to talk about
sort of these fascist
figures without invoking
some of these
psychopathological conditions
that it seemed to run like a
thread through many of them.
The other thing,
and this is also actually this
thing about Duterte's humor
is part one of a much longer chapter
on his what I call the presidential body,
kind of like attribute it to
what's the name of,
presidential two bodies,
I listening to the guy who
wrote that, do you remember?
- Bong Go and Senator Bato, sir?
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
The political theory is
the president's two bodies,
I can't remember.
Anyway I'm sure the political scientists
around here will know.
Anyway so the second half of the paper
is actually about his frequent
references to his illnesses
he likes to talk about his illnesses,
he likes to talk, nobody else
can talk about his illness
but he can.
You know he'll talk about
his Buerger's disease,
he'll talk about his is a
possibility that he has cancer.
In other words, he likes to
talk about his own mortality
and his own frailty,
in the same way that he likes
to talk about the abuses
that's he's encountered in the past.
So these are ways in which Duterte I think
materializes his own
condition as a way of sort
of anticipating criticisms
from his opponents.
Seek to roll that he's
got all these problems,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
He'll admitted them and
he'll say, well, so what?
You know, and then he will wax pathetic,
and he will he likes to invoke
a certain kind of patho,
he things but I can't do everything.
I'm probably going to die,
probably going to go to hell
and so forth.
And again, it's a way of sort of invoking,
I said, kind of pity on
the part of (indistinct).
These are two sides, on the one hand,
he likes to joke and
he likes to be abusive
and he likes to obscene on the other hand,
he will admit to his own
frailties and his own mortality
as a way of anticipating
criticism from (indistinct).
- So, sir, any follow ups check,
do you think that Duterte say that
to emotionally blackmail the whole nation?
- Oh, without doubt, without doubt.
I think Duterte's policies
of the drug killings
has resulted what I
call government of fear.
And again, this is part of the book
is that how all these contributed
to a certain governing style
where fear is at the center
of everything he goes
- Thanks, the next question
is from Orven Mallari,
Orven go ahead.
- Morning professor.
I asked him this question like in relation
to the Southeast Asian
politics and culture
and now that I'm with professor Harms,
as well as some people in this class.
I remember when, like this
talk really reminds me
of one of the earlier readings
that we did on Ben Anderson's
"The Idea of Power in Javanese Culture,"
specifically that one of the sections
where Anderson uses a
really remarkable anecdote
about the succession
crisis of like a Japanese,
you know the dead king's manhood
standing erect and on top.
Yeah you know that one.
- Yeah, of course, of course, yeah.
- I was wondering, like,
so, you know knowing you as
a student of Anderson like,
do you see like this whole phall,
like was that part of
your inspiration in this,
what about Duterte?
I was to follow up on that,
like ask Professor Harms said,
like ask you about how would
you rewrite that pieces
of the Scion idea of power?
- Yeah, well I dunno about that
that's another story we
could talk about later,
but, well, certainly, you know,
Ben has been an influence,
but I think much more
has been the influence
of certain feminists theorists
who've talked about sort of phallocentric
or phallocentrism
and that's been that's been
more important in this case.
In connection to that, I
remember in graduate school
Taking this classes in
precolonial South East Asia
with people like Oliver Walters
and various other people
who some of you probably remember,
and then we'll talk about the lingam
and Dave we'll talk about the phallus
and there would be no connection
with the sort of gendered
politics and the sexual politics
of pre-colonial Southeast
Asian sort of practices.
And I always used to
think that's very strange.
I mean, you're basically
talking about representations
of you know, male members, I said wow.
But you can see how something like Duterte
and the Duterte's
unwielding of the phallus
is in some ways very Southeast Asian.
I mean, harks all the
way back to you know,
precolonial notions of power,
which I don't make explicit in this paper,
but I don't think it's such a stretch
to make that connection so yeah.
- [Orven] Thank you.
- We have a question from Daniel Yonto
- Hello and thank you again.
I'm actually the first
words I learned in Tagalog
in the Philippines was tuklong.
And I think it's an interesting
aspect of their culture.
But I also was in Manila and the provinces
and I noticed that the jokes
were different in each places.
So I was curious if you
found that Duterte's stories
differed based on where he gave them at?
No, they were pretty consistent.
They were pretty consistent, yeah, yeah.
I mean they were always variations.
And lots of improvisation,
I remember once watching him
administer an oath of office
to newly appointed local leaders,
you know just the ceremony
that they come to the palace
and they all take their oath of office
and the person always does this.
And he comes in and, you know,
he's famous for sort of
being, looking to shovel.
So, you know, he's got his barong,
which is the formal dressing
but he's got the sleeves rolled up.
And he doesn't say good morning,
he doesn't say hi, how are you?
He says, well, you know,
I'm not feeling that great.
I think I ate something bad,
I had diarrhea the other
day and I'm really itchy.
And then he calls on one of the women
who who's about ticklers says
can you come over here
and scratch my back?
I mean, this is like
apropos nothing, right?
He doesn't, no sir,
it's just like, can you
scratch my back right here,
it's really itchy, right?
And of course everybody's
giggling because wow,
president, you know once
you to scratch his back,
that kind of thing.
Or he'll give a talk
in front of overseas
contract workers in Korea
and he'll pull a woman and he'll say,
oh what about giving me a kiss?
You know and they're all like
taking selfies and so excited.
And of course, everybody
else is outraged about this.
And, but yeah, he said he
thinks nothing of it, right?
And my favorite code is, you know,
he'll greet overseas contract workers
returning from Saudi Arabia.
And they'll say, well, it's
too bad you guys lost your job,
but you know what, I can give you a job,
why don't we go kill addicts?
That's kill addicts,
you know, that would
be a good job for you.
- Thank you very much.
- Yeah, tuklong.
- We originally had a
question form Rhodah Galamba
but he sent me a note saying
his question was already asked
and answered so we'll go
straight to Jim Scott.
- Hi, Jim, Jim.
- Jim you just need to unmute briefly.
- Can you hear me now?
- [Vincente] Yeah, yeah, hi Jim.
- Hi Vince, I can't wait for the book.
So it's exciting to get a glimpse into it.
I had a re a rather simple question
and that is the use of the word joke.
Your stories don't sound like jokes.
And there it's a raconteur,
it's just sort of personal history
with all of the edges that you point out,
but it's not the at least the kind of,
maybe I'm looking at it
through two western eyes
of a joke with a punchline and
a sort of suspense and so on.
And so it strikes me that
what Duterte is doing
is maybe something other than a joke
that we need a kind of special category.
And that therefore it's a little odd
to sort of put it in the
Freudian joke, category, right?
Anyway, what are the other ways
in which one might think
of what Duterte is doing
and it also occurred to me to wonder in,
for ordinary Filipinos,
this kind of talk would it
be confined to men drinking?
Would it, what kinds of social contexts
would this kind of
storytelling be confined?
We're not a kind of
presidential repertoire.
- You're absolutely right.
These are the kinds of stories men,
and some women would tell around
you know, drinking sessions, for example.
And so it's not unusual.
What happens though
is that those drinking
sessions are usually circles,
close circles.
And it's very rare that
they come come across
much more publicly in a
in a way you could argue
that Duterte's storytelling
has sort of created this
has nationalized drinking circle, right?
Which used to be very local,
very small, very intimate.
He's turned an intimate
gathering into very public
sort of situation.
The second point you make
is extremely interesting.
Are these jokes properly
sort of thought of
or is there something is another category
that we can use for it?
You know, I've struggled with that.
And one of the things that I use
as you can tell from the title of the book
is tricksterism, right?
I mean, I refer to Duterte
as a trickster figure,
which probably would
be again would connect
to more Southeast Asian context.
And the thing about the
trickster figure as you know
it's very widespread in the Philippines,
it's very widespread, it's Southeast Asia.
There isn't a single
Southeast Asian country
that doesn't have some
figure of the trickster
and the trickster it's a very
it's a very sort of uncanny
or very canny figure, I should stay
that combines aggressiveness
with a certain kind of attractiveness
that is funny but also cruel,
that is predatory but also
in some ways subversive,
in other words all these
different characteristics
that we associate with Duterte
that you can find in the trickster figure,
which is very different, say
from the trickster figure
that you might have a native American
sort of contexts, but in the Philippines
a trickster figure is omnipresent.
And I think that that's
what you get with Duterte
is not so much the concept.
Well, he is a storyteller,
yes, that's true.
But not so much a jokester
but more of a trickster.
And my use of Freud is
really an attempt to,
in some ways get at the
politics of this tricksterism
of this jokester because
I do think that freight is
so, I mean it's whatever criticism
you might lodge against them.
I still do think that he
was very very much keenly
aware of the power of
not just storytelling,
but of humor.
And it's very interesting,
'cause I hadn't read
jokes in the relationship
to the unconscious for years, for decades.
and when I read it, I was surprised.
I think something like 80% of
the jokes are anti-semitic.
I mean, all Jewish jokes,
you know, and he revels,
in telling me his these Jewish jokes.
And I mean, it really struck me as unusual
to anybody that was a tricksterism.
And then this idea of sort of elevating
a certain intimate acts of convention
defining exchanges to a national level.
- Yeah, thank you.
We're approaching our 1:20 mark.
And so I think I'll gracefully
bring it to a close here.
This has been a really
dynamic talk followed
by a really dynamic Q and A period.
So I just want to thank you for that.
Before we say goodbye formerly
you were mentioning drinking circles.
So I thought I would
take a moment to announce
the next Brown Bag in
two weeks on March 17th,
which will be about the melancholic play
of alcohol drinking Lee Su-min men
on the China Myanmar border.
So those of you who are
interested in this topic,
please join us with
that said, oh go ahead.
- Yeah, just one more thing about
this whole question of
drinking and intimacy.
One of the chapters in the book
talks about the problem of intimacy
and to making of community
as it relates to Duterte's
anti-drug program.
You know, as some of you might know
one of the ways in Duterte's
policy works is to what he
calls operation talk on.
That is to say he has to police
in conjunction with local officials,
build a list of actual
and suspected drug users
and drug dealers and this
essentially becomes the kill list.
Now, the question is how
does he develop this list?
Well he does so,
because everybody knows
everybody else in the community.
It's through intimacy
that you have the
development of community.
So the very conditions
for creating community
become the very conditions
for exposing it to this
sort of ongoing danger.
And for this reason,
rather than imagined community
that Ben Anderson, you
know famously talked about
what you get into Philippines
is what I call an auto-immune community,
a community of auto-immunity.
You know where the community
in order to come into being
actually enacts the very things
that endangers it from within so
and I think that's just a
tragedy, that is the tragedy
and that is the horrific sort
of consequences of having
someone like Duterte, you know
do this authoritarian drug.
It's not the first time
and it's not gonna be the last time,
but with Duterte you have the
most dramatic manifestation
of this audio Indian community.
So that's maybe a way to end this.
- That's a brilliant way to end it.
So just join me, everyone
and thanking professor Rafael
for this fantastic talk.
I'll stop the recording now
and then we can just linger
to say a polite goodbye.